aliens in Miami a video I never thought
we'd kick 2024 off with however this
whole thing seems a little too weird 100
cop cars for kids with sticks multiple
UFO sightings days before any mentioned
of aliens firsthand witnesses that look
like something out of the movie Alien
from 1980s police deleting footage a
certain list dropping same day there's a
lot to unpack so in this video we'll be
investigating the Miami alien situation
to find out if we really have ET amongst
us I need answers I need answers or is
this just a smoke screen part of a
bigger plan what better way to start
than finding someone who saw this police
Miami event with their own two eyes and
getting their take on the event
thankfully a friend Leia help her and
texted me she's down for the interview
despite being advised not to speak on
it oh [__] how we doing there he is Miss
Le help how you doing are you the Hat
this is just making some qu this this is
a serious day you guys are already too
happy you guys are all Smiley and [__]
we were always smiling this is
ridiculous miss helper thank you so much
for taking the time to to be with me
here today I need to hear exactly what
happened two nights ago in Bickle Miami
I was driving with a girlfriend and it's
right by the heat the Miami Heat arena
and there were hundreds and hundreds of
cop cars it literally looked like some
kind of terrorist response I've never
seen anything like that so you thought
there might be a shooter you thought
there might be a big emergency and your
response was to go and check it out yeah
so I thought there was some kind of like
terrorist attack but like everyone was
pretty still there were people on the
street like it's not as if the street
was empty so I was like oh whatever
let's like pull up and find out what's
going on so we get out and we start
talking to people asking them like
what's happening what's happening and I
kid you not there were I asked one guy
and he was like to me he saw some kind
of like I know it sounds ridiculous okay
creature that that was 7 ft tall I was
like this man is mad let's keep going so
I started talking to another person I
see this woman in a state of panic so I
go over to speak to her and she tells me
that she saw something that looked like
something out of the movie Alien from
1980s like I'm I'm dead serious so I'm
like okay this is insane let me get out
my phone so this is multiple sources
multip I start talking to so many
different people okay so I get out my
phone to start recording like obviously
you're doing now you want to document
and all this crazy stuff that's
happening and Miami PD come over to me
tell me that this is like a security
this is like a high security area I'm
not allowed to film they take my phone
make me delete what I'd recorded I
recorded like a couple of seconds so it
wasn't really that use so you're telling
me the police officer had you open your
phone go delet it did you have to go to
you recently deleted and clear it yeah
they everything they was just like
delete everything and then I don't know
if you know but the power went out in
the surrounding area as we drove away we
could see in the buildings the power
went out all the buildings just going
out yeah but you can literally look that
up like all the power in the surrounding
area went out um so yeah it was just the
craziest experience like and now the
police are saying that it was only um
some juvenile kids playing with sticks
and fireworks I just I just don't I just
don't believe that like it literally
looked like a terrorist response like it
look like some kind of 9911 response
Miss Leia hon have you ever seen horror
movies no I prefer to keep my mind clear
of those things I only watch comedies
and um psychological films that like
okay well in horror movies there's this
thing where people do uh really stupid
stuff so let's say there's ghosts in the
house they don't leave they decide to go
upstairs and check it out kind of sounds
pretty familiar you know you hear a ter
potential terrorist attack going on
hundreds of cop cars and you uh you just
go right into the I mean it was like I
mean would you not I'm like Batman Mrs
Halper did you witness this
man I didn't witness that man no but I
did see something really strange when
the helicopter was shining the light you
could see like a a reflection on the
building and I don't know I saw
something that was kind of creepy but at
that point I was just like I'm getting
out of here what kind of reflection I
don't know it could have been that man
it could have it could have been a
reflection of that man I didn't see that
man but it could be his reflection it
didn't look like a reflection of kids
playing with sticks what do you think
truly happened I don't know what
happened but I know what didn't happen I
know that juvenile kids weren't playing
with fireworks and sticks and then also
if you see what's going on in the world
right now like we just had the epine
files the names of the EP ep's Client
List be released so it seems like some
kind of distraction everybody's talking
about Miami when really we should be
talking about you know Joe Biden and
stepen Hawkings convenient timing
convenient timing that's always the case
isn't it that's what happened with um
when just Le Maxwell was in was in court
we had the whole like Amber herd and
Johnny Depp thing so convenient
distractions yes very convenient the
Puppet Masters are some what do you
think
happened that's what we're investigating
today here murn thank you so much for
the interview thank you great Insight
here I try my best okay I need to find
this
man okay so we just left Leia helper's
place I'm not too convinced on the alien
quite yet you know I need 100%
definitive proof of this thing happening
we are going to find the bottom of this
we're going to find the truth so next
stop is getting an Uber to the exact
place this alien incident went down see
there first son son how are you I'm good
man how are you did you hear about the
um the Miami alien stuff going on excuse
me no
[Music]
no I know this you know like aliens
alien like um like
amican huh American saes
EST alien uhhuh like in space like in
Miami
yeah in
Miami no more alen
me alen and Aliens no no you are alien
I'm alien yes okay I need to find my
brothers so my alien Brothers came to
pick me up and that's why I'm here so
now I'm going to this is where they were
so I'm going to find them just give me a
call if you see
them
um hermano me alien hermano the aliens
is your brother see or you can the other
planet see other planet other planet
what planet um it's far away it's very
far you know um Mars Mars or uh well
that's where I grew up and then my
parents got divorced and I moved to
Uranus tell about the the Mars yeah Mars
was pretty cool it was pretty cool the
chicks were hot the temperature it was
hot that's why I'm um that's why I look
like this I'm like you
know part black what kind of what uh G
genders see um oh see uh Sol do do
Quanto and uh in America we have many
many many Generals in America we have
many in America
male ER transal transgener yeah
transal gays
lesbian l
l b head I don't know yeah many many
letters many generals many generals I
identify as an alien so all right aliens
were just here looking I'm on the hunt
do you see any yet okay you see any I
see a transgender that's a transgender
right I think so I think that was a
transgender woman for me no because you
have a h General no genis jeans jeans
male but is no chain for female because
always
always the the the genus is male so what
are transgender then the transgender is
a concept not by
you're saying they're crazy so local
mental Distortion mental Distortion okay
all right sir what was your name Roberto
Sun it was beautiful meeting you thank
you sir wish me luck on finding the
aliens the YouTube is aliens aliens yes
I can show you my YouTube oh oh
my what is
this oh my because I I work with phot
photography oh yeah yeah that's what
it's okay it's the
photog it's the photography all right
can you wish me luck getting the finding
the aliens good
love uh good love fny the alien thank
you sir it beautiful I'll talk to you
soon all right where the [__] are they
look I'm not a crazy conspiracy theorist
I like facts based Uber drivers saying
transgender have it all in their head
facts Epstein Client List dropping the
same day as all of this drama facts it's
2024 and every election year we're hit
with new fear-mongering propaganda that
the sheep eat up facts Project Blue beam
clearly being implemented over time
facts anyways more on that later though
I'm now at the exact spot this event
went on so we need to get some input
from the people who work here themselves
all right bro you know there was aliens
here do you know anything about this did
you see the alien I wasn't even here I
was in New York you were you were in New
York do have you like heard anything
about it like any any information nope
nothing at all I have no idea you know
what happened here the other night with
like the aliens and all the police and
stuff no idea you how do you guys not
know this you work here you didn't see
all the police I didn't see anything I
feel like you got you're lying to me
right now no no no I'm totally honest
totally honest yes all right all right
thank you answer a quick question for a
video no no
no the things that happening yeah yeah
it's [__] so it was just miners
playing around yes why were there so
many cop cars though that happens police
they they want to like do do things like
big you know that's why they came here
like hundreds of them because the group
was so crowded it was crowded yes okay
did you see the kids with sticks were
you here of course yeah every year it
happens it's not the first okay all
right thank you
aliens
okay I have no idea what you're saying
but my editor speaks Spanish so we'll be
good what was your name Jessica nice to
meet you Jessica I'm sunny it's great to
meet you it was great to meet you you
know like what what happened here the
other night with the aliens the police
cars and everything what's your take on
what happened
happened the aliens aliens it was
aliens no I don't know bro I don't see
that why do you look nervous you look
like you don't want to answer and tell
me no i
n
person
okay okay all right thank you did you
hear about what happened here the other
night with like all the police cars and
all that stuff I seen it but I didn't
really pay much attention to it what's
your thesis on what happened what do you
think it is honestly have no idea do you
think that aliens are real could it have
possibly been an alien I ain't going to
lie I feel like they real I don't know
if the situation here was aliens but I
feel like they real they're saying it
was kids with sticks doesn't a 100
police cars sound a bit uh
suspicious 100% sounds a bit sus eh 100%
I'm with you all right
with you said all right thank you have a
good all the workers here they're scared
to answer you know I feel you I mean
everybody got opinions I feel like that
that was a little a little much all
right thank you bro I appreciate both
have a good one you too where were these
aliens I need answers I need
answers M on I see a couple security
guards back there behind me I'm going to
leave the camera here and go see if I
can get any them to uh give me any good
information cuz a lot of these people
are blowing smoke up my bum right now so
I want to find some good [__] enemy
combat come in closer closing in on the
guards and my mics went to [__] however
that's not going to stop me so I'll be
showing you the most accurate depiction
of what we talked about you asking me
about the aliens and [__] man it could
be so many different things I think it
could possibly be it could have been a
hologram nobody I know saw that I have a
bunch of people say they saw something
but no videos so I can just say I saw an
alien and a bunch of cops will show up
that's what's funny but if you're
calling that and saying you saw that of
course the PO going come really that yes
if I call right now and say there's a
bunch of kids inside of the market shed
and two got guns I'm going to have 20 40
50 cops here okay so he said if you call
the cops on an alien a bunch will show
up or if you call about guns a bunch
will show up both which aren't true
unless you're five stars and Lester
isn't available regardless we should
know what the police were called on that
night so I gave him a little
call thanks for calling dominoes all
right so I didn't even actually need to
talk to the police just as I was about
to give them a call a friend sent me
over this video that the official Miami
PD uh Instagram just posted where
they're answering all the questions that
we already have so let's just give it a
watch address a few clips that are going
viral on social media right now first
our response to that uh big incident in
Bayside Marketplace what happened was
there was about 50 or more juveniles
that were shooting fireworks at people
there was also some looting going on so
officers that were on that scene were
having a little bit of trouble
containing it so they called what is
called a Citywide 3 which every officer
in the city responded that's why you saw
so much police presence for for that
call to contain that crowd now there is
now video going viral of 8 to 10t aliens
walking around Bayside is actually just
a person walking with a Shadow so I can
confirm to you all here today right now
that there are no aliens in Miami in
Bayside Marketplace at the moment so
it's Friday I hope you guys have a great
weekend and stay
safe I'm not even sold on the idea of
aliens but this none of the stories are
matching up so far I mean the workers
were afraid to answer didn't want to
talk to me some people say they saw
stuff that I personally know police ask
people to delete stuff and then the
firsthand accounts that we did get were
saying that kids were playing with
sticks and it was a few kids now
apparently it was 50 kids with fireworks
where's the video of the kid with
fireworks like there's none of that
online anyways back to the interview
with the Mr security policeman I'm I'm
the supervisor the bid of the afternoon
shift if we had such an aliens here
people that's working and running these
K they want to come when they want to
come alien might come back they going to
be scared no they here because some kids
said it not saying it's not factual that
the kids saw it but nobody else on the
property did now tell me what sense that
makes with all these people around but
only four kids from what I'm hearing
here safe it could have been a part of
Project Blue beam I don't got to explain
that Holograms we got Holograms of
Biggie Tupac a bunch of guys if some
[__] really happened in Black the
government coming your president is
talking about
none of that happened none of that
happened could have been whatever we
really don't know the the tongue holds
the power of life for death I can say
things that can cause distraction and
people will go crazy cuz my tongue said
it for kids that come on there and say
that now they got people want to come
out here television oh you seen it but
nobody saying they saw nothing so at the
end of the day it is what it is it is
what it is they call you big they call
me big you see why they they call me 9
seconds interview's completed at the the
exact location where the alien sighting
was seen if you right behind this tree
where I am this is where all the cop
cars were it's raining I don't want to
break my camera so let's take it back
and debrief the information that we've
got so
far all right to recap we had Leia help
her and say she saw something big the
cops were being sus and asked her to
delete all the footage and all the power
went out we have based Uber driver who
saw a transgender from my home planet
the workers seeming almost scared to
answer which is very weird the police
claiming it's 50 kids with fireworks
which has just about as much proof as
the aliens themselves and the main
security guard who simply doesn't know
to be able to piece this all together
I'll sum up my 4-Hour conspiracy
conclusion for you guys the main agendas
pushed on to us are depopulation
removing God from society and the one
world order the underlying factor with
implementing all of these is controlling
our brains through controlled
programming music politicians
influencers social media fact Checkers
and and news being the main ones now
with all these different methods of
control they all lead back to a One
World Government one big fact Checker
regardless of if there was actual video
proof of this alien it would then just
be AI or photoshopped if the president
or news didn't cover it then it can't
possibly be real right we're progressing
to a world where the actual truth
doesn't matter only the fact checkers do
which conveniently come under any
serious matter you question humans only
care about what they see let's take
police killings for an example the
numbers have been consistent for years
but when the media button is pushed fact
Checkers social media boosting news
politicians talking about it controlled
influencers now it's the biggest issue
in the world when the whole time it was
the same amount of incidents that have
been happening the importance percentage
skyrocketed
100,000% when the incidence percentage
only increased 0% obviously I'm talking
about 2020 here
now I'm not justifying police killings
when I say this but at the same time
that sounds [__] bad and then
obviously when pushing these numbers
they twist the stories themselves so you
know something that was justified then
becomes unjustified maybe I picked a bad
example I don't know I'm a big I'm a
controversial guy but anyways this same
pushing tool can then be just as easily
used to suppress topics as well like the
Epstein case for example multiple Terror
and shooting events with a lot of
missing pieces and at the end of the day
this whole alien situation is extremely
suspect and all we know is that more
stuff is coming remember whenever you
see something question is this actually
important or was a button pushed to
build importance YouTube has already
fully demonetized me um giving me
strikes so I might be on my last legs
here if you guys enjoyed the video
please do hit the Subscribe Bell button
and join my Discord because that will be
a last resort for sunny Faz
if all of this goes to kaput and I'm
gone off of YouTube worst case the
channel gets fried I have another plan
in mind and all of us will congregate
there with that thank you so much for
watching transgender out